OK, another question that came in.
If Trump loses to Biden in a few days, how
will Trump Trump is justify it?
This is a great question because you have
you know, just look at our YouTube comments.
Look at the e-mails and tweets that I get.
David, you're going to cry on Election Day
when Joe Biden loses.
Trump's got this thing wrapped up.
Biden has no chance.
Trump's going to win easily.
All of this different stuff.
And I am not saying anything other than the
polls look good for Biden.
But it could go either way.
So I have taken a position that is based on
the facts.
No, Trump is can know that Donald Trump is
going to win.
And indeed, if Donald Trump loses, they're
not going to say, hey, you know what?
Biden ran the better campaign and more people
wanted Biden to win.
Biden won.
That's not what Trump's are going to say.
They have such cognitive dissonance that you
are going to see them come up with things
you can imagine and things you can't imagine.
Some Trump is, if Biden wins, will say Biden
cheated.
And by cheated, they might mean stuff with
absentee ballots.
They might mean manipulating voting machines.
They know who Facebook.
Who knows what.
But Biden cheated is going to be one story
that we are going to hear.
OK.
Biden won, but only because of the fake news
media that promoted him at every opportunity.
You're going to see a lot of that.
People going after the media saying the media
helped Joe Biden win.
You are going to hear Biden didn't really
win.
Trump didn't really lose.
Not from the standpoint of cheating, but from
the standpoint of it is just a fake story.
Trump really won, even though it's being reported
that Joe Biden won.
You're going to see some of that.
You will then see it's sort of like the five
stages of grief, denial, anger, bargaining,
Dabdoub denial, Ingleburn D. What's the depression
and then acceptance?
You will start to see some people say Trump
didn't want to win anyway.
Trump didn't.
They're gonna be rationalizing it to trump
the Trump had us for years.
He didn't have to do this.
He had a great life beforehand.
He's a rich guy.
Now he's going to go and make America great
by starting some TV network or who knows what.
You are going to see that.
Absolutely.
For sure.
And then you are also going to see some people
who say, Cauvin, Trump's already been laying
the groundwork for it, saying we had the greatest
economy.
I had great popularity.
And then the virus hit.
The plague came in from China.
As Donald Trump says, and while if Trump had
handled it properly, he would be sailing to
reelection, we've seen when a world leader
deals with the virus, well, they sail to reelection.
Look at Jacinda Ardern in New Zealand as an
example.
Trump could have done that.
But you will see people say hundred year pandemic
just got hit with the plague and that is why
Donald Trump lost.
Otherwise, he would have won.
It doesn't really count as a loss.
They will say, I want to hear from you.
What other explanations are we going to hear
from Trump lists and some we won't hear anything
from because they will disappear.
We will never hear from them again.
They will get off the social media retweeting
a fake news.
They will.
Stop doing.
They're just going to disappear, we're never
the ones that are really just embarrassed
are going to disappear.
Many will come up with excuses.
Let me know what you think those excuses will
be.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The last Friday bonus show before the 2020
election.
Senate election.
Congressional election.
Presidential election.
Many ballot measures.
Local races.
So much Friday.
Bonus show today.
And then it is election week.
I will see you then.